Americans of course are marking Memorial
Day today with heartfelt ceremonies to
honor service members who sacrificed
everything for this country those
sacrifices still a vivid memory for
veterans who were captured during the
Vietnam war 50 years ago this month 591
newly returned pows were special guests
of then president Richard Nixon at the
White House and those reunions became a
time-honored tradition for the group
many of the remaining pows gathered
again last week at the Nixon
Presidential Library near Los Angeles
and they say this could be their last
reunion Carter Evans was there
each one of these men was a prisoner of
war in Vietnam
everyone
together again at a reunion half a
century in the making a parade of
veterans hailed as Heroes a word that
still makes them uncomfortable the pows
we don't want people to honor us or call
us Heroes we're not Heroes we just
served our country and we got back with
our families Lieutenant Commander Mike
McGrath was a Navy pilot when he was
shot down over Vietnam he spent six
years in captivity at the infamous Hanoi
Hilton enduring brutal interrogations
they tortured us they broke every single
one of us I had a wife and three little
girls back home I certainly wanted to
see them again when navy pilot
Lieutenant Jack inch was shot down a
captor amputated his injured thumb with
no anesthesia no need for that
you have caused pain in our country now
it's time for you to suffer the torture
was just too painful and so I gave in
and I felt very guilty about that did
you feel like you betrayed your country
I did I did devastated Lieutenant
Commander Charlie Plum eventually
confessed to a higher ranking prisoner
the response hell everybody broke
there's not a man in this prison camp
who was as strong as he wanted to be
they communicated at Great risk through
sign language in a complex Morse code
that's us tapping and tap code through
the walls that was our line of
resistance that's what got us through
one guy would be down and you pick him
up when the surviving 591 Vietnam pows
were released in 1973 they came home to
ticker tape parades much to their
surprise it was somewhat confusing you
know because you know we were the guys
that didn't accomplish our mission never
has the White House been more proud than
it is tonight because of the guests we
have than I President Nixon invited all
of them to a party in Washington still
the largest dinner ever held at the
White House
[Music]
recreate it right down to the China and
silverware this month at the Nixon
Library in California this is the book I
gave President Nixon personally now a
retired Captain McGrath documented his
time as a pow with drawings that he
turned into a book displayed along with
other memories this is the actual
uniform you want that's the actual
uniform after returning home ninety
percent of the pows stayed in the
military and many found success in
civilian life there's 27 of us made
Admiral in general now mostly in their
80s they worry about a country divided
once again repeating mistakes didn't we
learn anything from Vietnam they're less
we are certainly much stronger
collectively than we are individually so
here we are 50 years later we're still
sticking together you didn't give up we
didn't give up for CBS mornings I'm
Carter revens in Yorba Linda California
oh boy there's a very famous flights out
of Vietnam the 591 who came home we
remember today the ones who did not but
the the celebration total silence until
the flight lifted off and exited
airspace of Vietnam and headed toward
America that's the moment when relief
was allowed to Rush In And there's just
Joy two families waiting for them yeah
too remarkable I think the fact that uh
90 of them chose to stay in the military
after their capture speaks volumes of
their sacrifice and service and Tony
you're right 58 000 perished in that war
in Vietnam and I'm happy that finally in
this country they're getting their due
because after the war and in the waning
days of the Vietnam War they were not
treated very well though these guys
received the ticker tape parade it
wasn't always like that for everybody
else